let me bring in Chris hangs I apologize
to Chris if he had to listen to that
Yahoo Sports NBA senior insider who
joins us now Chris good morning how's
morale morale you know as far as the NBA
go that thinking on people are
optimistic seem like we're the tractions
seemed like there was traction good
traction actually a couple weeks ago and
it seemed like that was deterred a
little bit last week but yesterday
seemed seemed like the league is doing
everything this power to try to you know
reassure to the players that things will
be safe and that it's in their best
interest to go over in Orlando a resume
play why do I have to be there for three
months if you're the elite teams gonna
play for a title it feels like other
sports are going to be playing in their
home stadiums why couldn't I have the
Eastern Conference Western Conference to
be played in those four cities and then
you have you know an NBA championship I
think um this is the best way to assure
that the players look there's players
out there that were really hesitant you
know even even prior to the George fluo
tragedy you know the racial tension that
we passed since then you know the
players were really reluctant to resume
play just because the unknowns are the
kovat virus you know you had started
speaking up on you know is even
necessary you know I supposed to CJ
McCollum of the Portland Trailblazers he
was like you know when the league opened
up the practice facilities back up you
know he was saying like he told me like
look man we got all these restrictions
you know at the practice early I gotta
be six feet away from my trainer while
I'm getting spotted you know how do you
lift properly doing that and if we have
all these restrictions going back to
just working out like is it even worth
it to be playing so I think the league
did it this way to try to you know make
sure that they have the best and safest
measures possible to try to get the
confidence of the players and so I think
that's why we they resorted to just
having it in isolated City if I gave the
NBA a do-over what do you think Adam
Silver would do
I think it'll do the same DP you know
there there are significant financial
ramifications for not resuming a season
for the players in the league and you
already had the durum or retweet that
that set the league really back as far
as finances go so I don't think he
changes anything you know he's been
really adamant from day one that he
wants to get the season restarted and
for the most part he has the majority of
the players in agreeance with him so I
don't think much would change at all and
I also wondered about these teams that
you know the the Bucks and Lakers earn
home court advantage but nobody's gonna
have a home court advantage in Orlando
and I know that they toyed with some
ideas some maybe rules for that but as
you know now there is no advantage for
the teams that have home court advantage
as a right now but you know the player
associations are still negotiating with
the league on you know you know some of
the rules in protocol that's going to
occur I'm down there and in in Orlando
so I wouldn't be surprised if some some
gimmicks are raised and some gimmicks
are approved you know I don't know what
you can do for a true home court
advantage you know there wasn't talk
about you know install installing a
court the Lakers Bucs bringing one of
their course but we all know a true home
court advantage is not true if you don't
have you know your fans they're rooting
for you providing that momentum and that
extra spark so I don't know what really
can be done honestly to to make sure
that the top C has an advantage in the
game I don't like you know giving the
ball up to you know somebody else
three times you know when you start in
each quarter you know just have the jump
ball and do you know do it a natural way
you don't want it like Michael Jordan
raised concerns in this call when owners
call with with Adam Silver is like you
don't want to gimmick it up like just
keep it simple we're talking to Chris
Haines Yahoo Sports NBA senior insider
if people didn't know what Kyrie Irving
was addressing the last week how would
you sum up what Kyrie has been credited
or accused of here in the last week or
so well he's been accused of being a
distraction
you know going against the Union yeah
you know all of that you know but uh you
know that call the call that he
organized last Friday it was a really
unifying call there were um it was a
platform to give younger players a voice
who ordinarily wouldn't have a voice or
who felt that like they couldn't speak
up man meetings prior and it was a
turnout of you know 80 plus players and
that's something that the players union
hasn't seen in quite some time when it
comes to their meetings in their zone
calls and so uh you know Kairi every no
he's pressed you know his concerns and
he he said he had no aspirations to go
over there in Orlando you know joy hour
wasn't agreeance Avery Bradley Carmelo
Anthony to an extent dominant Mitchell
raised concerns about his situation
being up for an extension this summer
but does Kyrie want to start a new
league Chris is that I haven't I haven't
heard I haven't heard that DP I haven't
heard that about Kane I can't confirm
that no calm but I you know there's
there's rumors that he's always said
that so I but I can't confirm if he said
that recently is he calculated or crazy
oh I wouldn't say crazy I wouldn't go
crazy DP cuz I'm not a medical I'll say
look you know Kyrie has always been
October Kyrie in Cleveland when I was a
Cleveland beat right up to a Cleveland
Plain Dealer
and for me he was there like the
toughest guy that I've ever had to cover
just trying to figure him out
you know one minute everything's cool
and next minute you know acts like he
doesn't know you or you know whatever
but he's always been fair to me I would
say that but I you know look is he going
against the gray not you know that
wasn't a Players Association sanctioned
call you know if last week because if it
was Chris Paul would have organizes so
and Kyrie is the VP of The Players
Association so this is you know this is
going against the grain a little bit but
it was a good call overall last week now
there's a snitch hotline in Orlando that
if you see somebody doing something
where they're putting other people at
risk
it it's not called the snitch hotline
right
and and and can you imagine all these
people saying I saw LeBron or I saw the
Greek freak and all of a sudden the
Commissioner says you know he suspends
LeBron for a game for endangering other
people here because of the snitch
hotline well I got a few things say
about that DP if it's not call if it's
not officially called a snitch hotline
it's going to become officially called a
you know that's what is going to be in a
second I expect that hotline to ring
like crazy if there are violations you
know they want to win wait a minute you
think that somebody would snitch you
think that Joe L M beads gonna call this
snitch hotline 1-800 narc and say that
the Greek freak I saw him out you know
and where you shouldn't be DP a player
saw LeBron James hopped the fence to do
whatever that Buzzard will ring you do
you you don't think they got opportunity
to take LeBron James out for a week or
so would you stretch would you snitch on
Adrian would general scheme if it helped
your career would you snitch on shams I
still love these some of these no pets
if you have card games we we have to
have singles ping-pong games we throw
away the cards after again like and and
are they allowed to smoke pot down there
because they're not testing Chris I'll
bet you were the safety measures that
they're taking you know and so like as
soon as they finish you know obviously
they're not wearing face masks you know
why they're playing but as soon as they
leave that arena
face mask face masks on all the time all
the time you know it's okay why are you
playing on the court you know sweating
up against everybody rubbing on I guess
everybody but as soon as you step off
the court face masses all the time
I didn't know if they would just have a
pot room because they have you know all
these different rooms set up for people
and you just hey six six feet of
distance you sponsor it Dorito sponsors
it and Taco Bell and you just let
everybody go in there and spark up and
since they're not testing for this well
you know if that's the case DP and I
don't think that'll be the case if
that's the case we're gonna have a
different brand of basketball
[Laughter]
final score will be forty four to forty
two are you going down um that's the
plan that's the plan
Wow what hotel do you get to stay in oh
I'm pretty sure you know whatever screw
up hotel they have you know look the
media is the last thing you know the
basketball Writers Association has been
negotiating with them the league on how
is it going to work for us is going to
be different to a few tears but they
haven't gotten back to us and sound
faster I understand we're low on the
totem pole but you know I expect you
know whatever hotel they got tucked in
the corner or motel that is you know now
you might get a motel but are you what
access are the writers gonna have to
these players aside from the games
themselves as far as I know um there
will be the the tear I forgot the tear
name but there be a tear that's on
campus and they'll have the access that
they would have is you know they'll be
at the press conference but still you
know you have the six feet rural
protocol so you have some access you
know with social distance proper social
dishes of measures being on campus and
now the ones that's in Orlando off
campus they are allowed to go to the
games but then they have to leave you
know I'm automatically after that and
then they have zoom press conferences
and so the thing is with that tear which
that tear DP I'm telling you in a lot of
ways I want to be a part that's here
because there's no restriction you're
outside the bubble you know they get to
go and go and leave as they please you
know go to a club or do whatever
you know you you know to tea other tea
on campus you know you were strictly
confined but you know it'll be real
interesting to see how the league comes
up with the protocol for the media who
can't be over there in Orlando and they
want to cover Lakers but they can't
afford the cost because I know it's
going to be expensive so it has to be
some incentive for a media to be out
there in Orlando to give them some
proper great access on that they
wouldn't get they weren't there and
Hardin loves the six feet separation
especially on defense like he's gonna
love because he plays defense that way
anyway right yeah well you you could say
that DP he has improved but I tell you
right now DP you're talking about what
whitey white was or in Orlando and not
in their home you know home cities for
for some of the playoff rounds I tell
you right now if this thing was in Vegas
DP which I was all in favor of here you
were you were really really has some
concerns about all those things you said
we're talking about whatever you know
there's some players who are known to
you know be hitting the club throughout
the week you know me you think you think
social distancing measures were really
being player Las Vegas so you know
Orlando was the ideal fit stay in touch
Chris no snitching DP no snitching Chris
no snitching Hanes Yahoo Sports NBA
insider thank you Chris be safe